all right I have reviewed the Star Wars
trilogy now I'm going to review part 1
of a trilogy of movies that tried to be
part of the Star Wars movies and yeah it
just wasn't Star Wars Episode one The
Phantom Menace in 3d
alright so Star Wars Episode one the
Phantom Menace starts off and
immediately you're like this doesn't
feel right I can by the fact that a big
Star Destroyer is not wasting a little
ship like the original Star Wars this is
building up the entire Star Wars saga so
I can roll with this what really threw
me for a loop it'll seem insignificant
but when I heard Natalie Portman talk
for the first time I was like this is
strange because she sounds like a
[ __ ] in the trailer she sounded like
Natalie Portman she sounded like a girl
in the Phantom Menace she actually
sounds like the Federation has gone too
far this time show me those two alright
she didn't say that's what she sounds
like and I just found that weird
insignificant yes but I was just like
why not just have her sound like a girl
if the Queen's supposed to be a
fourteen-year-old girl then make her
sound like a fourteen-year-old girl
which means don't dub her at all and I
bring this up because it just simply
shows that George Lucas has to meddle
with everything so in the Phantom Menace
the trade Federation's doing deals with
the Emperor when he's Darth Sidious he's
not the Emperor yet it's a big ploy so
Palpatine can become Chancellor and
that's pretty much it on the other hand
he wants Natalie Portman to sign this
treaty which you got to think he doesn't
want her to sign the treaty because if
she signs the treaty he won't get into
power so yeah makes me also think this
is the kind of movie that'll make kids
just check out and go play with their
transformers action figures or something
or Star Wars action figures since that's
the point of this movie the point of the
Phantom Menace was to sell action
figures that is it in any case we get
down to Naboo the main planet in this
movie and we meet Jar Jar Binks now when
I first met Jar Jar Binks I was like
this guy is nothing like I thought he
was going to be I don't know what I
thought Jar Jar Binks was going to be
like I just didn't think he would be Jar
Jar Binks I didn't think he'd set black
people back 50 years I guess is what I'm
trying to say in any case we're down on
that boo in the big action scenes the
big excitement comes from Jedi just
cleaning house with these droids which I
kind of sees it's kind of cool to see
the first time cuz you're like oh yeah
you know Jedi are just kicking ass and I
like seeing Jedi kick ass and we didn't
really see that in the old Star Wars
movies so now we get to see Jedi in
their prime and that's pretty cool for a
little while after that it just feels
like you put on god mode in a video game
real art I'm invincible and I'm just
kicking the [ __ ] out of everything fun
for a few minutes and you're like I'd
like a challenge please
that's pretty much the Phantom Menace
after that to go to Tatooine so they can
meet a really bad kid actor who is going
to be Darth Vader cuz he's Anakin
Skywalker which I don't get the point of
this why not just make anakin 17 years
old like luke then we could relate to
him be kind of follow his story instead
he's this kid which we don't care about
and he's going to be an adult in the
next movie so why even have him a kid
yeah but the real point of Tatooine
comes out soon enough
it's not to meet the bad kid actor who's
Anakin Skywalker it's not to have the
Queen be safe while they're getting the
ship part so they can get the Queen to
Corazon now it's the pod race so they
can make a few video games about pod
racing
that's what Star Wars has become ladies
and gentlemen the fact that it's in 3d
now just confirms that and everyone's
like oh yeah the best part of Phantom
Menace is the pod race I remember the
first time I saw Phantom Menace I was
like it's kind of cool but it's not as
cool as I thought it would be it's not
like it's the video game burn out set in
a galaxy far far away for the big screen
or anything like that it's just it just
kind of happens and it's not exciting
then after that they get to Khorasan and
that's when every human being alive gets
bored shitless because it has the pseudo
political dialogue you know Palpatine's
like negotiations and please give me
power the whole point of the next half
hour to 45 minutes is just to dethrone
the Chancellor Palpatine could rise in
power that's it do this show a kid The
Phantom Menace I swear to you when
Khorasan comes on screen
five minutes later he's off playing with
action figures again he doesn't care
about it it's not particularly
interesting political dialogue so we
don't care about it no one cares about
Corazon and then when they leave course
not jar jar's all these all cheering and
[ __ ] and the music Rises like a cool
it's awesome it's a party this just
tells me that George Lucas knows that
Khorasan is a piece of [ __ ] part in this
movie he's like let's just get off this
[ __ ] planet let's just anywhere else
even he knows to show that leaving is a
celebration I find that just funny and
then we get back to Naboo and we're
setting up for the big finale of this
movie there's too much going on in the
end of this movie a couple of them I can
see yeah this needs to be in the movie
obi-wan and qui-gon jinn throwing down
with Darth Maul that should be in the
movie female voice Padme and the rest of
the troops going after the Viceroy that
should be in the movie Anakin Skywalker
accidentally flying a ship into space
and accidentally blowing up the big bad
guy ship should not be in the movie the
gun guns fighting the droids it's not
exciting it's just it's it's dumb
slapstick should not be in the movie
which I'll say this about the N fight a
lot of people are like ah
it's all like choreograph well yeah it's
choreographed I'll say it's really
entertaining it's cool to see a bad guy
you know like a Sith Lord taking on two
Jedi I'm not saying the whole thing is
good or that it ended well but I'm
saying while the throwing down you're
like yeah cool all right if for nothing
else in the Phantom Menace I wanted to
see that and I did there's actually
scene in that end fight where obi-wan
and qui-gon are getting ready and
obi-wan Sykes at Darth Maul and qui-gon
actually hits him it kind of showed that
obi-wan and cloggin we're kind of using
the Force to be on the same page to
mentally connect with each other I
thought that was really cool but it
doesn't make up for a two hour and 20
minute movie a [ __ ] the fight ends
with obi-wan holding on to this ledge
and Darth Maul standing over him instead
of Darth Maul doing something logical
like using force push and hitting
obi-wan down this big pit or at least
dropping his lightsaber on his head or
something Darth Maul is just swinging
his lightsaber like this like what why
is he doing he's not even hitting him
he's a few feet away from him he's just
making pretty sparks for the kids at
home and then obi-wan wins the fight and
kills Darth Maul in a way that's a lot
like being Boba Fett but it's not as
stupid as Boba Fett's death because
Darth Maul is not remotely as cool as
Boba Fett there's another thing after
qui-gon OOP spoiler alert dies they burn
his body kind of like how Luke burned
Darth Vader's body at the end of Return
of the Jedi I just kind of thought that
Luke did that because that was his way
of doing it apparently Luke knew that
that's just the Jedi way Jedi burned the
Jedi bodies good for that guy for just
knowing it's like everything in phantom
menace is forced to fit together because
Lucas thought everything has to be
connected like Anakin building c-3po I
was just like why does that have to
happen not everyone has to be a part of
the Phantom Menace no apparently they do
though because now we can sell new c-3po
and r2d2 toys and how does the 3d 2/3 it
is funny about the 3d it's almost like
it was converted by two different people
sometimes I was like actually that's not
that bad at all but that works
other times I was like is that even in
3d now is it worth the price of
admission to see it in 3d oh no in the
end Star Wars set black people back 50
years Asians back thirty years bad kid
actors back 20 years at Natalie Portman
back ten years although she won an Oscar
ten years later so the world balances
out for her everyone else I apologize I
will say you will like Star Wars Episode
one The Phantom Menace if you just want
to talk [ __ ] about a movie and you're
drunk
yeah knows a party Oh another flaming
medic Lorien it's not a real drink
should be even the animatronics are
those Trade Federation guys they suck I
mean there's just one scene where this
guy's like impossible nothing kicked it
- ah shoot
really you're George Lucas you have an
unlimited budget and that was what you
thought was good enough I would expect
nothing less from the guy who says a han
Solo never shot first or some lying
[ __ ] like that he said that is
stupid however if you want to see an
absurdly entertaining review of the
Phantom Menace check out red letter
media I put the link below to take you
right to his Phantom Menace review check
it out dude there's anything you wanted
me to say but I didn't say he says it he
locks it down in such a good case that
the biggest Phantom Menace advocate will
be like you're right it's [ __ ] love
it
hate it watch that so have you seen Star
Wars Episode one The Phantom Menace have
you seen it in 3d what did you think of
it bring it here's your chance to lay it
all out here where were you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you liked what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more